vous êtes bien sur lcp public sénat
c'est l'heure de parlement hebdo 45
minutes pour refaire l'actualité
politique et parlementaire de la semaine
en compagnie de mickaël jamais bonjour
capture bonjour michael cette semaine on
reviendra sur les hésitations du
gouvernement concernant la réforme du
travail du code du travail la
présentation du projet de loi a été
repoussée pour donner plus de temps au
dialogue en tout cas officiellement le
texte divise les syndicats
mais aussi la gauche les députés ont
voté de nouvelles mesures
antiterroristes une personne pourrait
être due quatre heures après un contrôle
d'identité et les forces de l'ordre
pourront faire usage de leurs armes hors
du cadre de légitime défense est un
projet de loi qui divise à gauche mais
aussi à droite
et puis comme chaque année le salon de
l'agriculture a rassemblé les foules et
attirer les responsables politiques
notamment à droite que les concurrents
une éventuelle primaire se sont succédé
avec chacun sa proposition pour le monde
agricole
bonjour j'ai karoutchi vous êtes
l'invité cette semaine de part le bref
vous allez commenter évidemment toute
cette actualité vous êtes sénateur des
hauts-de-seine et katia évidemment
l'actualité le commence par lundi lundi
avec ségolène royal qui relance la
polémique sur la durée de vie des
centrales nucléaires
trois mois après l'arrivée de l'après la
coop 21 l arrivée de certains
écologistes au gouvernement la ministre
de l'environnement veut prolonger la
durée de vie des centrales nucléaires de
dix ans une déclaration qui a provoqué
des réactions géré landrieu s'est un peu
vert sous conditions mais qui offre de
nouvelles perspectives aux centrales
nucléaires françaises
leur durée de vie pourrait être prolongé
de dix ans si l'autorité de sûreté
nucléaire donne son feu vert oui je
donnerais l'autorisation de prolongation
de dix ans de centrales qui sont déjà
amortis dont ils produiront une
électricité à meilleur marché mais dans
le contexte je le rappelle de la baisse
de la part du nucléaire de 75 à 50%
savoir la production des restes objecté
pour monter en puissance sur le
renouvelable
à l'arrivée un mix énergétique maintenu
avec une baisse de 75 à 50 % pour la
part du nucléaire d'ici 2025
l'écologiste jean vincent placé à peine
arrivé au gouvernement n'y voit pas une
remise en cause de la loi de transition
énergétique qu'il y aura quelques
centrales qui ont vaincu vocation est
modernisé mais je conclus là dessus et
je le dis aussi pour mes collègues du
gouvernement
attention la filière nucléaire
aujourd'hui telle qu'elle est avec les
échecs de nos pères et en finlande et à
flamanville
c'est plutôt au bord de la faillite
forte et très sincèrement je vois même
pas comment on va trouver l'argent pour
prolonger prolonger ou non les centrales
est avant tout une question de coût et
l'opération ne serait pas vraiment
rentable si on voulait prolonger de dix
ans leur espérance de vie si j'ose dire
il s'agit de faire une opération qui ne
sortent de lifting qu'on appelle le
grand carénage en langage nucléaire qui
coûte cent milliards d'euros c'est la
cour des comptes qui donne ce chiffre
100 milliards d'euros aujourd'hui le
nucléaire il faut comprendre et sortir
du mythe que c'est moins cher pour tenir
l'objectif de 50% sur la part de
nucléaire d'ici 2025
les seules fermetures prévues
aujourd'hui concerne les deux réacteurs
de la centrale de fessenheim
avez vous compris ça vous fait rien mais
vous comprenez vous qu'on protège et des
prolongations
qu'est ce qui vous fait rire rien
d'abord franchement on sait bien que en
prolongeant la durée de vie si
l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire le le
garantie d'un certain nombre de
centrales
ça veut dire qu'on remet en cause de 75
qui passe à 50% ce pas sérieux de dire
dans neuf ans on sera passé de 75 à 50
la rencontre avec les gens les centrales
enfin c'est même la provocation imbécile
de dire ça bon deuxième élément moi je
trouve très drôle vous fait rentrer 3
écolo des cas 3 et colloques soit entre
un gouvernement vous annoncer la
prolongation de vie des centrales
nucléaires
je ne demandais s'ils allaient partir du
gouvernement aussitôt arrivé alors tu es
grand ils sont restés vous avez pu en
parler peut-être avec jo maso vous
connaissez bien je parle pas de
nucléaire avec jean massart vous avez
pas je suis pas sûr d'ailleurs qu'on ne
soit pas en accord absolu en la matière
mais non je trouve que voilà arrive un
moment un peu de sérieux ne nuit pas moi
je suis pour le fait que les centrales
si on a des certitudes puisse être
prolongé
de là à dire que ça ne change rien aux
75 qui passe à 50 % que ça ne change
rien à la politique écologique du
gouvernement
arrêtons la plaisanterie on n'a plus un
rond les caisses sont vides
on essaye de remettre que françois
hollande en 2012 vos fourneaux le plus
près on et voilà on essaie de prolonger
la durée de vie des centrales par de
l'électricité moins chère
parce qu'il faut bien un moment qu'on
trouve de la ressource voilà je suis
d'accord c'est normal que ce soit
l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire parce que
si un risque il faut évidemment pas le
faire enfin on sent bien que la
politique écologique de madame royal ou
de monsieur hollande s'arrête sur le mur
de la réalité de ce qu'on voudra l'aîné
entend dire que le nucléaire c'est
toujours les merlus ont suffi pour
l'énergie nucléaire donc je vais pas
commencer à hurler contre la
prolongation où les écolos les écolos ça
suffit comme avec un bonhomme nicolas
sarkozy l'environnement ça commence à
bien faire
des écolos je crois qu'il faut
simplement il ya une écologie réaliste
il ya un environnement possible
et puis il ya des réalités économiques
qui a des réalités qui sont là bon votre
bien on avance et on arrête de faire du
dogmatisme écologique
d'ailleurs comme y'a plus personne
europe ecologie les verts pas très grave
alors on parler d'un autre sujet
important cette semaine c'est à mardi le
gouvernement a décidé comme vous savez
roger karoutchi de reporter de deux
semaines le projet de loi elle commande
minimum officiellement manuel valls ou
être retravaillé le texte est mieux
l'expliquer face à la grogne des
syndicats et d'une partie de la gauche
qui exige son retrait le texte doit être
présenté en conseil des ministres le 24
mars
état des lieux avec et les à berthelot
mais il avait assuré qu'il irait
jusqu'au bout
pourtant lundi face à la pression manuel
valls est obligé de reculer
le projet de loi elle connerie ne sera
plus présentée le 9 mars en conseil des
ministres mais le 24 15 jours de délai
de quoi laisser plus de temps à la
concertation
quand le texte est apparu il y a eu des
incompréhensions ce qu'a dit le chef de
l'état des incompréhensions des des
questions il faut avoir peur de discuter
de dialoguer une critique à peine voilée
de la méthode musclée de manuel valls
le premier ministre a toujours dit qu'il
voulait aller vite sur ce texte
la dernière réforme majeure du
quinquennat de françois hollande
problème les partenaires sociaux ont peu
été consultés et certaine mesure les ont
très vite braquer on a le premier
ministre qui va encore une fois à coups
de menton en dix ans et je veux aller
jusqu'au bout et vous allez voir ce que
vous allez voir et puis huit jours après
on retire le texte on dit bah non il
faut prendre le temps du débat de la
concertation c'est dommage qu'il n'y ai
pas pensé il ya huit jours qu'il fallait
concertée une occasion manquée d'aboutir
à un texte consensuel y compris avec les
parlementaires
l'ailé gauche du ps s'oppose fortement à
certaines mesures
au point pour le gouvernement de laisser
entendre qu'il pourrait passer en force
si les parlementaires faisaient de la
résistance
de quoi braquer davantage les députés la
ministre
elle tient bon je suis pas là
aujourd'hui pour vous donner l'issue de
ces concertations alors même qu'elle
commence c'est il faut être dans ce
dialogue je suis ministre du dialogue
social et ce dialogue social est
essentiel quinze jours de dialogue donc
pour négocier et trouver des compromis
et tenter de pacifier les relations du
gouvernement avec les syndicats et avec
sa majorité à l'égard de manuel valls a
semblé vouloir aller vite avec ce texte
finalement il est reporté officiellement
pour donner plus de temps au dialogue
un commentaire sur la méthode vous
n'avez pas le sentiment que mal il faut
arrêter de se fiche du monde
enfin ce gouvernement nous a dit à
quatre cinq mois vous allez voir on va
réformer le code du travail
on s'y met tout de suite qu'est ce
qu'ils ont fait pendant 4 5
parce que d'un coup d'un seul on l'a
découvert ya huit jours que y avait pas
eu de concertation avec les syndicats y
avait pas eu assez de concertation au
sein du ps avait pas eu mais ils ont
fait quoi par an 4 5 mois des bouffes
ils ont craint personne
dur à battre entre eux mais alors qu'est
ce qu'ils ont fait un texte de loi ça se
prépare
c'est avant que ça arrive aux conseils
des milices que s'est concerté travail
et découvrir au moment de passer au
conseil vise qu il arrete concerter avec
personne
c'est absolument invraisemblable et
d'ailleurs c'est pas crédible
moi je pense qu'à réalité il ya eu de la
concertation il ya eu des discussions et
qu'ils ont voulu passer outre et comme
manuel valls a dit moi il me faut des
espaces il me faut de la libération de
l'entreprise parce qu'il faut inverser
la courbe du chômage
parce qu'aussi nos lancers résultat
parce qu'il faut des résultats
donc je passe en force et puis ils
voient qu'il ya des réactions
hollande qui se met en retrait dit oh là
là là oh la la qu'est ce qui se passe au
point du fail qui déjeunent ensemble
soit disant pour se rabibocher mais où
est-ce qu'on est le premier ministre
habib au tchèque le président sur un
texte aurait dû être travaillé avant sur
un texte sur l'avant projet duquel
j'avais dit après tout si ça reste comme
un rat pourquoi pas pourquoi pas sauf
que maintenant on ne sait plus du tout
ce qui aura dedans
donc on va être d'une prudence extrême
et on va attendre de voir ce qui met
dedans
moi je crains qu'un texte qui était soi
disant fait pour plus de dialogue dans
les entreprises
une véritable un véritable
assouplissement pour que les entreprises
puissent créer de l'emploi
au bout du bout finissent par ce plus de
réglementations plus de contrainte parce
qu'on aura écouté tout le monde parce
qu'ils veulent pas de valve
parce que l'ue n'ait fait peur parce
qu'on veut pas une manif dans la rue
jusqu'à ce que hollande et discréditer
parce que le gouvernement n'a plus aucun
point parce qu'il ya plus de majorité à
l'assemblée
parce que c'est la fin des temps et qu
on a compris qu'elle allait 2016 c'était
une année noire ou blanche comme vous
voulez mais je l'est parce qu'il ya plus
de majorité pour gouverner il ya plus de
gouvernements de lignes de leur a pas de
majorité n'y aura pas de majorité sur ce
texte
mais où parce que j'aurais aimé à la
semaine d'abord j'attends de savoir quel
est le texte que vous et je vous dise
oui oui les le texte c'est quoi le texte
qu'ils enlèvent tous les éléments
d'assouplissement pour mettre que des
éléments de contrainte je veux pas ce
texte des jeunes moins jeunes de la rue
ça peut terminer comme le cpe à l'époque
on me compare ça avec le cpe le cpe a
été retiré quand y avait eu un mois de
manif
là on retire un texte avant même qu'ils
aient une manif on est encore plus fort
peu fort à bientôt il fera de mal et
virtuelles sur facebook et le
gouvernement et une pétition d'ailleurs
qu'ils attaqueraient gouvernements
puissants capables autoritaire qui va
faire bouger les choses en ce pays il ya
un syndicat étudiant qui dit si
éventuellement vous bougez pas je retire
et je fais descendre dans la rue et hop
on a retiré le texte faible en italie
année on va réformer ce pays tue en
italie matteo renzi a réussi alors par
le marché du travail mais mal leur
maison à unna véracité et bien sûr
contre eux d'abord alors premiers
éléments
reconnaissons que ce genre de texte 20
début de mandat un président élu sur un
projet mais ça dans son projet et
considère que dès le début du mandat il
faut le faire voter avec une majorité
solide et un gouvernement stable
je reconnais que faire vouloir faire
voter des choses lourdes en fin de
parcours quasi dans la période
électorale
quand on n'a plus de majorité quand le
sénat est opposée à la majorité
gouvernementale
ça devient le parcours du combattant et
quand en plus le parti dit majoritaire
n'existe plus que par le fait de
posséder un immeuble parce que pour le
reste y a plus rien ils s'étripent joie
que les députés quittent le parti
un passé c'est mission impossible parce
que on sait pas ce que va être donné ce
texte à l'assemblée
et une fois qu'il se retire à
l'assemblée on verra bien ce qui se
passe au cépage etc a aussi écouté ce
que disait françois hollande en début de
semaine que vous réservez juste à me
rassurer tout de suite on écoute comme
le texte a donné lieu à des
interrogations
c'est assez légitime à des
questionnements g comprend pourquoi le
premier ministre a prévu une
concertation vaut mieux prendre du temps
pour mieux en gagner et pour faire en
sorte que ce soit à la fin la france
qu'ils puissent réussir ensemble les
organisations syndicales les
organisations également patronales
seront reçus et puis il y aura une
conclusion qui forcément devra amener
les uns et les autres à prendre leurs
responsabilités c'est-à-dire à faire en
sorte que nous puissions avancer
moi j'aurai votre réaction sur une opra
ce qu'était d'or à l'intérieur de cette
phrase prendre du temps pour mieux en
gagner
le texte est en préparation depuis six
mois ils pouvaient pas en gagner en
préparant le texte vous attendez
d'annoncer le texte pour des remous fait
il vaut mieux le retirer pour rediscuter
parce qu'on va en gagner c'est à dire
que on a mis six mois on avait réussi à
rien faire on annonce on le retire on va
renégocier
donc ça veut dire qu'il sera même pas
prêt fin mars parce que si un mouvement
de grève le 31 on va essayer d'éviter de
panne on sait le texte avant donc on va
encore gagner du temps que vous disiez
tout à l'heure ce que vous disiez manuel
valls veut aller plus loin il veut
pousser les feux jusqu'au bout le
préformateur comment se dit lui même oui
et alors son nom mais le vrai sujet
c'est que depuis 2012
vous avez un ps qui en réalité tu en
deux blocs un bloc social libéral et un
bloc socialiste à l'archaïque bon ces
deux blocs ont essayé de coexister
aujourd'hui ne coexistent plus alors
vous avez un walsky d'un pousseur macron
sur madame elcom riz sorgho et puis de
l'autre côté vous avez les arcs qui
bouge pas pour être bien ça veut dire
que le présent hollande a été élu sur un
faux projet sur un projet qui n'était
pas capable d'imposer à son temps on
entend beaucoup à droite que c'est la
vérité c'est la vérité la preuve c'est
que même pour cette réforme du code du
travail annoncée ya six mois on avait
une
petit de droite rejet des eaux dit même
qu'il fait une politique de droite
françois hollande
non il fait pas de politique du tout il
va au fil de l'eau il n'y a plus rien
qui se fait l'état n'existe quasi plus
enfin écoutez la révision
constitutionnelle regard enfin tout il
n'ya plus rien qui ne demande pas aux
gâteaux rien qui tient alors on va voir
cette loi c'est une surprise comme cette
fois c'est dans que j'obtienne non c'est
une surprise au sénat la position du
sénat cette semaine la droite
sénatoriale a changé de pied un petit
peu sur les pieds de la déchéance d'un
homme raisonnable
vous allez y venir voir regarder le
petit sujet co créée par sophie dans mon
quotidien l'est républicain compter sur
le sénat à majorité de droite pour
ramener à sa version initiale le projet
de révision constitutionnelle édulcoré
on février par les députés socialistes
le patron des sénateurs l'est
républicain s'était engagé à
réintroduire la référence à la
binationalité mais à deux semaines du
début de l'examen du texte en séance
bruno retailleau y renonce nous
n'offrirons pas nous diront oui à la
déchéance mais non à l'apatridie
c'est à dire que nous inscrirons pas les
binationaux dans le texte de la
constitution ça peut choquer certains je
le comprends parfaitement mais nous
respecterons la parole du président de
république exprimée et j étais devant
tous les parlementaires à versailles
ils avaient dit non à l'apatridie eh
bien nous inscrirons dans le texte que
l'apatridie est interdite
une volte face qu'il justifie par le
refus d'une posture politicienne
une volte face qui pourrait rendre
possible la synthèse jusque là
impossible dans la classe politique
reste la question de la patrie dit que
les députés socialistes voulaient
supprimer
c'est autour de ce point que devrait
désormais se cristalliser le débat roger
karoutchi comment expliquez vous cette
volte face qui a pris un peu le concept
survolt sincèrement c'est pas une bonne
phase 1 13 de nos nous disions dès le
début que ce soit sur l'état d'urgence
que ce soit sur la déchéance de
nationalité faut-il une révision
constitutionnelle
on n'est pas sûr mais comment ne voulait
pas donner le sentiment de bloquer
quelque chose qui allait dans le bon
sens
on a dit ok au discours du président de
la république au congrès et donc moi
j'avais dît si la révision
constitutionnelle prend ces deux
éléments
je la voterai alors il
tous les carabistouilles à l'assemblée
au sein du ps et tous on n'y comprenait
plus rien on sait plus ce qu'il voulait
c'est chez vous non non non pourquoi
parce que nous la commission des lois va
réécrire et va pas établir l'état
d'urgence telles quelles sans élément
supplémentaire de ce qui a été rajoutée
à l'assemblée elle va remettre la
déchéance de nationalité est comme un
débat mais ça c'est vrai qu'un débat sur
est-ce que ça concerne que les
binationaux ou les monos nationaux d'or
je puis dire qui est pas un débat clos
ni à gauche ni à droite je reconnais eh
bien on va simplement mettre dans la
révision constitutionnelle que on
n'autorise pas si je peux leur dire
l'apatridie alors est ce que ça veut
dire que ce texte réécrit par la
commission des lois du sénat puis par le
sénat lui-même dans quinze jours est ce
que ça veut dire que ce texte trouve à
une majorité à l'assemblée parce que
vous avez la question est ce qu'on va au
congrès
je n'en sais rien moi j'ai le sentiment
profond est peu de tromper que la gauche
explosé maintenant sur le code du
travail n'obéit plus à rien sur la
révision constitutionnelle et que vous
verrez qu'un certain nombre de gens au
ps et parmi les députés ps diront
déchéance de nationalité
binational mollo nationaux apatridie
patrice et non vous pensez sans leur âge
je pense que on va avoir beaucoup de mal
à trouver pour cette révision
concessionnels d'une majorité à
l'assemblée maintenant quelle que soit
la rédaction du sénat c'est pour cela
que la rédaction un petit peu changé
c'est que vous êtes sages on se dit il
faudrait quand même pas que le ps se
foutent de la gueule du monde trop
longtemps ils sont pas capables de se
mettre d'accord entre eux c'est quand
même pas nous qui allons porter la
responsabilité d'un éventuel échec sur
la déchéance de nationalité
parce qu'ils sont pas capables de se
mettre d'accord nous nous sommes
raisonnables nous nous avions dit oui au
début et on était très clair dans les
différents responsables de votre parti
je pense à nicolas sarkozy dont la jupe
et qui n'était pas du tout d'accord sur
ce jouet pas mais les deux avaient dit
ni l'un ni l'autre ne sont députés ou
sester mais les deux avaient dit que
s'il était député ou sénateur
-votre les deux les deux donc c'est pas
une question de division au sein des
républicains c'est vrai qu'on pouvait se
dire entre les articles du code civil
qui qui finalement permettent la
déchéance de nationalité et l'état
d'urgence qui a été validé
le conseil constitutionnel on n'a pas
forcément besoin d'une révision mais
comme on ne voulait pas être en arrière
de la main et pas faire de politique
politicienne par rapport au président la
république on avait dit si ça donne le
sentiment que le pays se mobilise contre
le terrorisme et contre tous les risques
c'est ok après on a assisté à la
pantalonnade à gauche donc que chacun
porte ses responsabilités on va passer
aux mercredis vous propose d'aller faire
un petit détour par le salon de
l'agriculture
on va dire que c'est une forme de
tradition française presque un passage
obligé roger karoutchi les personnalités
politiques vont défiler eux aussi au
salon de l'agriculture
à gauche comme à droite certains ont été
très bien accueillis pour d'autres est
un petit peu plus difficile à regarder
ils y vont pour séduire l'électorat
agricole pour tester leur popularité
aussi le jour de l'inauguration du salon
hués et insultés
françois hollande a vite été fixée sur
la sienne pour l'upa qui nous écoute
plus
tous après crevaison aux élevages deux
jours plus tard son premier ministre
évoque lui des échanges rugueux mais
respectueux il ya déjà la gueule ouverte
c'est normal qu'on les entende et
collant dans leur détresse
mais il faut aussi des remises en cause
à droite il y a comme un parfum de
primaire dans les allées du salon
la concurrence fait rage au jeu mercredi
entre vaches et cochons trois ténors du
parti les républicains déambulent sans
jamais se croiser nicolas sarkozy
profite d'une visite de sept heures pour
proposer un plan marshall de 100
millions d'euros
c'est un choix de vie ou de mort la
baisse des charges est indispensable
elle passera également par une
diminution des dépenses de huit plans
aussitôt taclé par françois fillon
la seule priorité pour l'ex premier
ministre des mesures urgentes pour
sauver l'agriculture française record
d'assiduité pour bruno le maire l'ancien
ministre de l'agriculture passe trois
jours aux côtés des agriculteurs
de son côté alain juppé candidat lui
aussi à la primaire de droite et favori
s'y voit déjà en pleine crise agricole
le coupable est tout trouvé pour marine
le pen la présidente du fn parti à la
conquête des agriculteurs pendant près
de dix heures maintenant engagée
violent bras de fer avec bruxelles parce
que pour sauver la peau des éleveurs et
des agriculteurs français
phil hogan c'est une évidence
phil hogan le commissaire européen à
l'agriculture qui ne s'attardera pas
dans les allées du salon préférence
engouffré avec le ministre de
l'agriculture pour une réunion de
travail
de quoi boucler une semaine très
politique à la gauche était service
minimum à gauche qu'à la droite pardon
service maximum normal obligatoire ce
salon de l'agriculture a été politique
on a vu depuis
franchement des semaines on semble
découvrir tous les ans que tout le monde
et tous les responsables prison mais
vous savez ce que c'est encore
nécessaire ça ça vaut oui parce que pour
les parlementaires par exemple des zones
rurales oui il ya les agriculteurs de
leur région s'est pas seulement un
passage politique c'est aussi la défense
des produits de chaque région donc moi
je trouve que c'est que c'est bien
qu'une façon de mesurer son influence
aussi et ça va se jouer auprès des
médias parce que c'est l'heure à chaque
fois on calcule plus de monde pour alain
juppé pour nicolas sarkozy pour eux
c'est plus les médias qu'ils font que
nous donc je sais pas si ça évalue quoi
que ce soit ça évalue la colère du monde
rural
beaucoup plus que de savoir pour qui ils
vont voter demain matin mais voilà oui
c'est important parce que c'est à la
fois une vitrine
et c'est en même temps d'une table de
revendications et d'expression de la
colère n'est annoncée comme la
fédération du négoce sarkozy un plan
marshall pour les agriculteurs pendant
et en plein pendant ce salon penser que
c'est vraiment parce que d'abord
meilleur ennemi ali s'opposent avons
tenu une convention sur le monde
agricole il ya déjà un certain temps
donc bien avant le le salon et nicolas
sarkozy avait déjà fait un discours où
il parlait déjà de ce plan marshall il
n'a pas annoncé au salon il a redit au
salon ce qu'il avait annoncé
dans cette convention dans le public un
jeu rappelle d'ailleurs qu'ici même au
sénat nous avons voté une proposition de
loi sur le monde agricole et sur la
défense agriculteurs et gérard larcher
il ya beaucoup tenu et il a eu raison et
et donc nous ne découvrons pas le
malaise agricole avec le salon de
l'agriculture
nous nous avons fait un certain nombre
de propositions je suis pas d'accord sur
est ce qu'il faut est ce qu'il faut pas
il faut à la fois des mesures urgentes
bien sûr et il faut des mesures
structurelles parce que pardon mais on
parle du malaise agricole de la crise
agricole
tous les 2-3 ans depuis un moment mais
bon c'est bien la colère et maximum
parce que tout est convergent le fait
qu'il y ait l'embargo russe le fait
d'éléments extérieurs laterrière vous
aussi c'est la grande distribution
oui mais pardon cette loi de 2008 elle a
été corrigé plusieurs fois sincèrement
on n'a pas découvert en 2016 les effets
de loi de 2008 donc ça je n'y crois
guère
je crois qu'il ya un certain nombre
d'éléments structurels au niveau
européen qu'il faut évidemment changé
quand on dit dans notre reportage qui
s'est pas attardé monsieur phil hogan
dans les dalles et c'est vrai il
paraissait très le retrouver mais
d'accord d'abord que ces crises et il
aurait pu passer tranquille dans le je
pense pas que les agriculteurs le
connaissent en réalité mais c'est pas le
sujet le sujet c'est que l'europe a
défini d'autres priorités que
l'agriculture c'était le point central
dans les années 60
ça ne l'est plus aujourd'hui donc il
faut voir comment re fait ça au niveau
européen
avoir une vraie politique agricole et
peut être mises de l'agriculture très
proche d amy j'y verse que c'était la
cas du plasma politique tout son art et
culture roger karoutchi
les élus de droite n'ont fait que taper
sur stéphane folch
c'est le nouveau bouquet maintient elle
vous montre ça christiane taubira non
avec un doigt mois ne manquent pas
jamais été
ni vulgaire ni injurieux à son égard ne
serait pas téléphone je le serai pas
plus à l'égard de stéphane le foll
je trouve que le ministre de
l'agriculture a tort d'être à la fois le
ministre de l'agriculture est le porte
parole du gouvernement
quand on est de mise de l'agriculture on
se consacre au monde agricole on fait un
peu moins de politique un peu plus
d'agriculture et ce côté pardon hein
mais même dans les séances de questions
d'actualité le soin au sénat ou à
l'assemblée très arrogant entre et je
fais tout je comprends pas pourquoi vous
parlez cinq hôtels à 100 quand on voit
la situation réelle des éleveurs et de
bien d agriculture un peu de modestie
dans les résultats et un peu de modestie
dans l'attitude de nuit pas alors
mercredi toujours rire vous reparler de
cet amendement qui a été ajoutée puis
retirée du projet de loi sur la
biodiversité il prévoyait de supprimer
le principe du pollueur payeur il a
disparu sous la pression écoutez la
réaction de la ministre on y revient je
crois qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui sont
montés au créneau
quelque part ça a permis de lancer l'
alerte mais de toute façon les
difficultés de rédaction cet amendement
les aurait vus et on les aurait géré
encore une fois jamais au grand jamais
moi en tant qu'écologiste ni ségolène en
rien ne laisserait passer une atteinte
quelconque ou une régression du droit de
l'environnement
alors comment est ce possible une telle
cacophonie tel amendement qui se
glissent comme ça ça il ya toujours des
amendements qui sont ou des cavaliers ou
d'aidé
des amendements de lobby qui arrivent
dans les textes et là moi j'avais vu
tout de suite d'ailleurs c'était à
l'assemblée pas au sénat mais j'avais eu
tout de suite
la réaction des élus toutes couleurs
politiques confondues d'ailleurs par
exemple de bretagne qui disaient non
mais attendez
nous on s'est pris l'amoco cadiz le
torrey canyon et les autres vous croyez
quand même pas qu'on peut accepter ça
donc non ça arrive je partage totalement
leur avis il ya souvent une action des
lobbys pourtant qu'on a essayé de cadre
et d'un au parlement qui n'est pas
toujours très réussie c'est le moins
qu'on puisse les questions pas ce jeudi
puisque jeudi les députés vote de
nouvelles mesures antiterroristes dans
le cadre de la réforme pénale une
retenue de quatre heures après un
contrôle d'identité un assouplissement
de visages des armes par les forces de
l'ordre encore un contrôle administratif
pour un individu qui revient du jihad
telles sont les mesures majeures voté
cette semaine par les députés on y
revient avec alex plichon les députés
sont rentrés dans le vif du sujet ils
ont donné leur feu vert à une retenue de
quatre heures après un contrôle
d'identité
une mesure qui a crispé dans les bancs
des écologistes et des frondeurs il faut
être bien naïf pour croire que la durée
de quatre heures n'est que de simples
vérifications vous autres réduisez
vous-même l'arbitraire dans la loi
malgré quelques voix dissidentes la
droite prend fait et cause pour la
mesure certains souhaiteraient même voir
cette durée allongée quatre heures ça
risque d'être un peu court
surtout lorsqu'il s'agit de comparer les
fiches dans différents services
internationaux autre disposition phare
du projet de loi
l'assouplissement de l'usagé des armes
par les forces de l'ordre à la tribune
pascal popelin s'est voulu rassurant
l'objectif de cet article n'est en rien
une volonté de donner aux forces de
l'ordre
un permis de tuer mais pour le radical
alain tour et il n'est pas nécessaire de
modifier la loi
il y a systématiquement des
acquittements qui sont faits en matière
de légitime défense
eric ciotti lui s'est félicité de ce
qu'il considère comme une légère avancée
vous
avait enfin souhaité répondre à nos
attentes dernières dispositions majeures
adopté la création d'un contrôle
administratif pour les individus de
retour du djihad pour lesquelles la mise
en examen n'est pas justifiée faute de
preuves
il ya eu beaucoup de mesures assez forte
votée à l'assemblée dans le cadre de ce
texte
c'est un bon texte est équilibré ça
répond à la menace pour vous nous c'est
un texte qui est une avancée me dire que
ça répond à la malade sa soeur mort ce
franchement aller interroger les
français dans la rue on leur dit alors
les gens qui avaient un du djihad
rendais pas compte mettre un contrôle
administratif
déjà il se dit waouh c'est qu'on répand
la terreur par la terreur bon c'est pas
assez
enfin voilà bon très bien pour le reste
les quatre heures à l'issue d'un
contrôle d'identité moi je trouve ça
c'est normal l'attendait on nous dit
régulièrement tel ou tel est fiché dans
les services de renseignement est passé
au travers des mailles du filet laissons
au moins nos services pour travailler
comparer croiser les fichiers 4 heures
je ne sais pas si ça suffit mais en tout
cas
faisons un peu les choses quant à
l'utilisation des armes par la police
enfin on est on est à l'envers comme
cela c'est la police de la république
c'est quoi
qu'est ce qu'il ya en a des milices
maintenant dans la police on est où on
est pauvre et fils
on n'est pas dans certains secteurs où
on a des polices parallèles c'est la
police de la république avec les règles
de la police les contrôles de la police
et et on est en train quasiment de leur
dire oh là là surtout vous avez quasi
dangereux que de sonder fois globaux
tous mais il ya des règles mais les
règles internes associées résiste enfin
on assouplit les règles on dit
éventuellement on va pas vous mettre en
cause chaque fois et on va un peu
étendre les cas de légitime défense
est ce que pour autant non mais attendez
enfin de partout toujours vrai sirop
loin de la golf pardon est ce que pour
autant vous pouvez toujours parler de la
xive a c'est ce que je disais tout à
l'heure de la même manière qui a
une cassure entre les libéraux et les
interventionnistes sur l'économie il ya
la ligne cazeneuve si je puis dire un
peu plus sensible quand même aux
problèmes de police et de sécurité et
des lignes et bien encore très de la
ligne du ministre de la justice monsieur
envoie également attendant il est là
depuis trop peu mais je pense que
l'actuelle garde des sceaux je trouve
que l'actuelle garde des sceaux semble
vouloir dire qu'il ne veut pas se mettre
en contradiction avec monsieur cazenave
chaque fois allez on verra bien à
l'arrivée c'est pour ça que vous parlez
de laxisme tout à l'heure en passer un
autre dossier c'est le dossier
migratoire qui était au coeur du 34e
sommet franco britannique qui a eu lieu
à amiens
françois hollande a mis en garde l'ong
contre la possibilité des conséquences
du brésil
par contre les britanniques ont donné un
peu plus d'argent pour aider notamment
sur la question des migrants face avec
clotilde hasard 22 millions pour
renforcer la sécurité à calais
c'est la somme que david cameron
s'engage à débloquer à amiens le premier
ministre britannique est resté ferme la
manche toi resté infranchissable pour
les migrants nous avons des frontières
solide nous les surveillons ensemble
pour dire aux gens qu'ils devraient
demander l'asile en france
s'ils ne le font pas ils devraient
retourner dans leur pays seule
concession
les mineurs isolés pourront rejoindre
leur famille outre manche mais seulement
celles déjà régularisés cette nouvelle
aide financière est la bienvenue pour
calais où la situation ne cesse de
s'enliser
la france gère au quotidien la
sécurisation du port et du tunnel sous
la manche mais aussi l'accueil des
migrants toujours nombreux et décidé à
rejoindre le royaume uni sur fond de
campagne pour le référendum sur le bric
site
françois hollande a tenu à rappeler
l'importance du rôle de la
grande-bretagne dans l'union européenne
à l'heure de cette grave crise
migratoire pas responsabilité c'est de
travailler avec le gouvernement
britannique pour que nous puissions
trouver les meilleures solutions pour
traiter la question des réfugiés
parce que ce qui est en cause là c'était
plus simplement la présence d'un pays
dans l'union européenne c'est l'europe
elle-même qui est en jeu les deux pays
ont par ailleurs renforcé leurs
relations bilatérales
par la signature d'un contrat d'armement
et d'énergie roger karoutchi je vous
présente ma tin six roquettes avec nous
bonjour votre partenaire du scan qui
vous poser quelques questions d'ici
quelques minutes
d'abord katia évidemment sur ce sommet
oui alors sur cette solidarité peut-être
un peu forcée des anglais 22 millions
d'euros que qu'est ce que vous en pensez
est-ce que l'entente cordiale ou leur
porte bien est ce que les britanniques
sont aux côtés de la france face à cette
grave crise est-ce que 22 millions
d'euros c'est suffisant donc ton de
cordiale qui à 115 ans a subi bien des
coups de canif
non je pense que c'est vrai que les
britanniques ont intérêt à ce que ce
soit la france qui fasse le job pour eux
à la frontière je perds la loi accorde
tout à fait tout à fait mais je ne
conteste pas sauf que c'est pas 20
millions d'euros qui vont changer la
nature des choses sauf que la
responsabilité française elle est
d'avoir laissé se créer la jungle à
calais parce que il est recalé le cas en
parachute
il arrive à quai les eaux traversées le
pays quand même donc à un moment la
responsabilité autorités françaises de
savoir qui a le droit de demander
l'asile en france qui n'a pas le droit
d'être sur le territoire national avant
qu'ils arrivent à calais est une réalité
alors on semble on semble commencent à
prendre le problème du démantèlement de
la jungle
on verra jusqu'où ça va aller mais je je
je trouve que la position britannique
elle est à la fois confortable de dire
vous donne un peu d'argent mais vous
vous débrouillez et vous les garder chez
vous et d'un autre côté elle est
compliquée parce que est ce que les
britanniques vont quitter l'europe mais
je trouve que de toute façon les
britanniques négocié beaucoup mieux que
la france par rapport à l'europe je
claque fois qu' il ya quelque chose qui
va pas y rené goscinny racines on s'en
va et hop ils obtiennent des avantages
ils obtiennent des rééquilibrant voix
nous sauter le fameux money back de
margaret thatcher
maintenant on a cameron qui se
débrouillent finalement pas mal et nous
à côté on fait quand même mais c'est une
autre voie de porto kurde europe ça veut
dire mes dents mais ça veut dire qu'en
réalité comme on a cassé pour deux par
des mesures économiques mais aussi par
des mesures symboliques la force de
l'axé franco allemand kik
instruisez l'europe nous nous n'avons
plus cette espèce de poids d'influencé
qui était le pois franco allemand alors
aujourd'hui on négocie un peu avec les
royaume uni ont négocié un peu avec un
email mais bon en tout cas la france
comme tout autre pays va devoir
accueillir des demandeurs d'asile est ce
qu'il ya des choses qui sont faites
est-ce que vous avez des informations
sûres mais le gouvernement français
s'était engagé à dire 30 milles en juin
2015 sur l'année 2015 2016 on devait en
recevoir 30 milles je reconnais que nous
n'avons ce qu'on appelle la
relocalisation qu'assez peu de syriens
et dira qu'il ya en réalité parce que
c'est comme ça pour le moment on a
surtout nous des éthiopiens et des
somaliens des soudanais
on a en réalité assez peu de gens qui
viennent des théâtres d'opération et
syrie irak
on nous dit que nos envoyés de l'ofpra
ou de l'office français d'immigration
dans les hot spots vont faire en sorte
qu' on en est davantage
moi ma crainte c'est que en réalité on a
augmenté de 25 % en 2015 le nombre de
demandeurs d'asile alors de mona on n'a
pas la capacité de savoir combien on en
aura en 2016 et des gens parlent de
relocalisation d'un certain nombre de
séries à dire à ta question d sub et
mais non sa fin
sap a été financièrement anticipées on a
dit et j'ai voté pour
on va construire un peu de places
d'accueil mais pas assez par rapport à
une augmentation pareil
donc on va avoir comme disent le comme
d'une visite à l'odeur des frictions en
2016-2017 des frictions ça veut dire
qu'on a des milliers de demandeurs
d'asile qu'on ne sait pas logés on a
saturé les hôtels on a saturé
l'hébergement d'urgence et il n'y a pas
de places d'accueil
j'en sais rien je savais pas et le
gouvernement non plus ça sauf quelques
robes ou quoi ça fait craindre des
incidents ça fait craindre des violences
et moi je pense que on n'a pas un
programme de logements suffisants et en
même temps on n'a pas un programme de
contrôle suffisant parce que si on peut
pas les loger pas leur donner de jack et
qu'on n'a pas d'argent pour les
allocations
à un moment il faut dire stop voilà je
vous dise matile sirop est avec nous
elle attend depuis tout à l'heure c'est
la loupe du scan
mathilde 0,7 à bout oui bonjour à roger
karoutchi
vous faites partie des soutiens de
nicolas sarkozy pour la primaire vous le
pousser à se déclarer rapidement
candidat alors que me souhaite attendre
l'été vous avez des jeunes et je crois
avec lui mardi
est-ce que vous avez réussir à le
convaincre sur sa candidature sur le
calendrier il est lui le président de la
famille politique est bon il ya eu les
élections je le mali les élections
internes du parti au mois de janvier
franchement le climat à l'intérieur du
parti est tel que il peut dire qu'il a
permis l'apaisement après les divisions
du passé
il ne souhaite pas entrer trop vite dans
le débat des primaires c'est au moins de
novembre
les français sont pas dessus c'est pour
ça que quand je mets les autres façons
déjà dessus
abbas a eu non pas la responsabilité la
famille politique
donc ils peuvent aller et venir dire
sans doute sur la candidature nicolas
d'or les plus de doute sur la
candidature
allez moi j'appelle à cette candidature
et et sincèrement je le dis comme ça
j'ai pas été le mieux traité du
quinquennat précédent 1 il y en a qui
ont été ministres beaucoup plus
longtemps que moi est mieux traité que
moi et qui aujourd'hui ne trouve que des
défauts quinquennat précédent
moi j'ai toujours considéré quand j'ai
mal quand je dis j'allais dire j'ai
quitté le ministère non vous fait
quitter le lycée roule quittez pas de
vous-mêmes sauf drame
bon quand on m'avait dit émissaire vous
n'avez entendu de ma part aucun mot
désagréable parce que c'était un honneur
d'être ministre mais c'est pas un dû et
c'est pas une propriété vous ne l'êtes
plus vous ne l'êtes plus le point ça ne
change pas mes opinions sur le fait que
j'ai beaucoup d'estimé pour tous les
candidats et pour tous les responsables
avec qui je suis en bons termes
parce que ce sont des hommes d'état et
des hommes publics compétents mais en
même temps nous sommes dans une période
de crise
moi je crains je le dis franchement que
2016-2017 d'une aggravation de la crise
financière de la crise économie de la
crise du terrorisme de la crise
sécuritaire et je sais que dans ces
situations là il n'y a pas seulement la
qualité d'homme d'état qui va jouer il
ya la force
et à la pugnacité il ya la volonté et
moi j'ai vu comment nicolas a fait en
2008 quand il ya eu la crise financière
que les banques s'écroulent est que
l'économie
les économies des français allaient
disparaître je les ai vus me dire à moi
minutes chargé des relations avec le
parlement
il me faut un accord du parlement avant
d'aller en allemagne négocier je le veux
en quatre jours je lui dis c'est
impossible c'est inconstitutionnel
on a réuni tous les présidents de
groupes de gauche et de droite à
l'elysée et nicolas sarkozy a obtenu au
moins chacun d'entre eux s'engagent à ne
pas faire de recours devant le conseil
constitutionnel
jamais vu jamais vu qui peut faire ça
pour sauver le pays qui peut voilà c'est
tout alors après les autres tout le
monde est très bien j'aime tout le monde
toujours de la primaire qui s'annonce
quand même assez rude pendant la
campagne va être publiée à destination
des candidats
si vous deviez le rédiger quel en serait
le premier prof le premier principe il
est clair pour tout le monde
nous appartenons à la même famille
politique presque tous ceux qui sont
déjà engagés dans cette primaire ont
appartenu au même gouvernement
alors on peut défendre ses convictions
des formes des idées un peu différente
pour autant c'est pas la peine de
petites phrases c'est pas la peine de
mots aigres-doux parce qu'au lendemain
de la primaire faudra tous se rassembler
pour assurer l'alternance en 2017 et
gagné contre la gauche
voilà vous étiez avec les militants des
hauts de seine
mercredi soir et pour une consultation
sur le projet du parti
vous les avaient incités à faire des
propositions fortes oui et je vous cite
à secouer le cocotier
alors qu'est ce que ça veut dire est ce
que vous trouvez que les responsables
politiques de droite sont trop frileux
sur le plan des idées pour quoi dedans
et les responsables politiques en
général
moi le premier parce que enfin sortez
dans la rue on va on va se prendre des
coups sur la tête enfin pas que nous
avons aussi le journaliste mais tout le
monde est discréditée c'est les gens
sont exaspérés les gens ne croient plus
dans la vie publique
il faut donc des propositions fortes
pour changer le système pour changer les
propositions pour rendre l'action
crédible pour faire en sorte que celui
qui sera élu président la république en
100 jours changent tout
est-ce que les gens n'y croient plus
donc oui il faut faire des propositions
et c'est pas une question d'âge un
j'entends des commentaires en tout genre
pour les candidats à la présidentielle
ce n'est pas une question d'âge qu'une
question d'état d'esprit qui veut
changer le pays qui veut faire en fait
en 2017 en 1958 moi je suis pour
allons-y alors avec mathilde on va vous
interrogé aussi sur sa cette interview
donnée au magazine elle du président a
parlé à l'occasion de l'ag lutte ils
étaient démunis c'est toujours social a
rebaptisé le ministère de la famille oui
il veut le rebaptiser en ministère des
femmes avaient vu ce matin la manif pour
tous ont été signés ainsi que hervé
mariton député de la drôme des
républicains pour vous cela ce pluriel
signifie quoi qu'est ce que ça change je
ne sais pas enfin 6 de la symbolique
pour faire plaisir moi je n'ai pas voté
la loi taubira je n'ai pas voté contre
je me suis abstenu j'étais plutôt
favorable à l'article 1
un peu hésitant pour ne pas dire très
hésitant sur les articles sur
l'affiliation à l'adoption donc je me
suis abstenu
mais sincèrement la famille on peut la
considérer comme on veut que ça veut
dire de passer de la famille à l'effet
bailly sérielle ça veut rien faire
différent alors que la famille
monoparentale homoparentale terrassé la
famille moi je suis pour une politique
familiale je supporte pas le fait de
fiscaliser les allocations familiales ou
de les baisser
je ne supporte pas le fait de baisser le
quotient familial
c'était une force de notre pays la
république et au pluriel
ça vous plaît non moi je pense qu'on
aurait pu rester un ministère de la
famille et qu'à l'intérieur on pouvait
intégrer toutes les familles le fait je
vois pas sincèrement c'est du jeu j'ai
entendu laurence rossignol que je
respecte
d'autres qu'elle était sénatrice mais
que je respecte mais franchement
l'explication ne tient pas la route
merci merci a garoché c'est le mot de la
fin on se retrouve la semaine prochaine
même lieu même heure merci mathilde
mardi